when you tell somebody that you are  responsible for you it's actually really  empowering it means that you can  actually strive to do better and that's  so amazing and the fact that you only  become a man when you are responsible  for people and I find that that's so  fascinating because politically there's  like this division about which party is  the party of the responsibility party  right and it's always like the left  which don't want people to be  responsible for anything whether it's  your health whether it's your diet  whether it's your relationships whether  it's how much money you have you know  don't be responsible for that because  don't worry we'll give you a social  safety net so this system at large  doesn't want people to be responsible  for themselves and so it's funny because  that's sort of like trickling down into  what it means to be a man and it really  just tells men you don't need to be  responsible for anything and so men  never become men